otro cadáver Es sacado de entre las
ruinas
una ambulancia lo lleva a la morgue
donde será formalmente identificado
otra víctima que añadirá la lista de
fallecidos más tarde será llevado al
nuevo cementerio en el viejo cementerio
ya no hay espacio
es una masacre nadie quiere pasar por
esto pero no tenemos opción deseo una
pronta recuperación a los heridos he
perdido a mi tía a su hija y a su hijo
según la tradición musulmana alabar a
los muertos es un ritual sagrado aquí en
estas unidades móviles se les lava con
respecto uno tras otro en medio de la
angustia la incomprensión y a veces la
rabia este antiguo ministro de salud
espera aportar un poco de Consuelo
estamos con nuestros ciudadanos
compartimos su dolor aquí todo el mundo
sufre nosotros sufrimos el gobierno está
haciendo todo lo que puede y nuestros
ciudadanos pueden verlo
aún así puede que no sea suficiente en
este campamento instalado en un
parqueadero tiendas de campaña albergan
a personas cuyas casas Están en ruinas
estamos haciendo todo lo posible para
ayudar tenemos nuevas cajas de
donaciones que llegaron y estamos
esperando el visto bueno del gobernador
para distribuirla muchos refugiados
sirios se encuentran en este campamento
una minoría vulnerable porque más
aislada mientras que en osmaníe algunos
pueden alojarse con familiares otros
tienen que afrontar el frío de la noche
en tiendas de campaña